Гамбург - північнонімецький мегаполіс та університетське місто.
У цій будівлі Дітмар Махуле досі має свій офіс.
Професор зараз на пенсії, а до 1999 року був керівником дипломної роботи з питань містобудування Мохаммеда Атти.
Той вчився у Німеччині під прізвищем ель Амір.
Професор Махуле шокований від усвідомлення того, що його студент був одним із пілотів, які спрямували літаки у ВТЦ в Нью-Йорку.
Я знаю іншу людину. Я знаю Мохаммеда ель Аміра. Він був молодим студентом, як і багато інших у Гамбурзі.
З тією лише різницею, що він був мусульманином.
Дуже релігійним і дуже активним. І розмірковуючи, чи ми чогось не помітили, нічого не спадає на думку.
Атта знімав квартиру неподалік від університету.
У ній він зустрічався з іншими ісламістами - троє з чотирьох пілотів-смертників, що скоїли теракти 11 вересня, жили у Гамбурзі.
Чому студент-відмінник радикалізувався, його професор може лише здогадуватися.
Подібно до молодих людей, які є відданими справі і не дурними, Мохаммед хотів зробити свій внесок у розвиток чогось.
І ось цей свій запал він, очевидно, нікуди не зміг застосувати.
Навіть у мене, бо ми ніколи не доходили до таких розмов.
І, мабуть, з іншими теж. А от в мечеті Аль-Кудс, очевидно, це стало можливим.
Це мечеть салафітів. Атта й інші терористи відвідували її кілька разів. Мечеть наразі закрили.
Вона була добре відомою владі як місце зустрічі потенційних ісламістів, -
зізнається тодішній керівник Гамбурзького відомства з охорони Конституції.
Ми підійшли дуже близько - набагато ближче, ніж ми припускали. Ми знали деяких людей з оточення, але ми не могли розпізнати якісь структури.
І перш за все ми не розпізнали, що вони задумали.
А готувалися вони до нападів. Ісламісти поїхали до навчального табору в Афганістані та зустрічалися з лідером "Аль-Каїди" бен Ладеном.
Цікаво, що за кілька місяців до терактів 11 вересня Атта знову з'явився в університеті.
Тоді я помітив, що на вулиці прийшли якісь люди. Подивився, а там  -Мохаммед. Він дивився у своєму типовому стилі, і я сказав: Мохаммеде, звідки ти?
Ми так давно не бачилися. Зачекай хвилину, ми за мить закінчимо.
Потім я знову зосередився на занятті, а коли закінчив і вийшов, його вже не було.
Махуле впевнений, що Мохамед Атта хотів попрощатися…
Він був одним з 19 терористів-смертників, які 20 років тому - 11 вересня 2001 року - вчинили теракти,
що стали найбільшими за кількістю жертв в історії США.
Тоді загинули майже три тисячі людей, серед яких дванадцятеро мали українське походження.
Найбільше життів забрало падіння в Нью-Йорку веж-близнюків ВТЦ - Всесвітнього торгового центру.
Саме в нього терористи спрямували два захоплених літаки.
Третій літак впав на будівлю Пентагону і зруйнував частину штабквартири міністерства оборони США.
Ще один лайнер розбився неподалік містечка Шанксвілл у штаті Пенсильванія після того,
як пасажири і команда лайнера стали чинити опір терористам на борту.
Президент США Джо Байден вже підписав указ про розсекречення протягом шести місяців документів про розслідування цих терактів.
Це було однією з його виборчих обіцянок. На цьому вже майже 20 років наполягали і родичі жертв терактів.